il ya un évêque s'est fait pire
il ya tout là
après à joris terre
je pense qu'on est encore dans la plaie
qui sait qu'il faut nettoyer
il ya quelque chose de vivant danois
dans le on fait quoi maintenant comment
on fait dans le concret l'eau
jean travaille et je fais quoi pour que
ça aille mieux elles vivent à des
kilomètres l'une de l'autre pourtant
jolie en et mélanie font le même constat
la mort de joyce et chaque one les a
transformés en tant qu'infirmière les
intentions sont obèses mais comment le
faire concrètement ce pas si sanglots à
joliette le malaise qui s'est installé
pire si ce n'est pas rare de faire un
faux pas faire peur de dire un mot de
travers pour pour faire reprocher des
choses mais aussi pourquoi les blessés
un manouane les attikameks sont plus
conscients de leurs droits quoi je
vienne qui ressort de son côté le devoir
de les défendre ce que j'ai pris
conscience qu'on a conscience et
beaucoup d'être
le rôle d'avocat si je l'avais que j'ai
toujours défendues mais
là c'est sa part c'est notre peuple il
ya des choses qui pensent pull mais
encore aujourd'hui elle n'arrive pas à
rassurer les membres de sa communauté
qui ont peur de se rendre à l'hôpital de
joliette mais c'est sûr qu'ils ont des
craintes que c'est ce qui en a qui
veulent puis y aller il y a pourtant eu
des rapprochements avec la communauté de
manouane il y a eu des formations ou
obligatoire pour le personnel de
l'hôpital de joliette des formations de
quatre heures base essentiellement sur
l'histoire des premières nations je mets
10 26 ans un peu ouvert les esprits à
avoir
avoir plus de compassion à comprendre un
peu mieux des fois des comportements ou
des je me dis je pense qu'on a regagné
je veux croire ça c'est l'individu parce
que même si tu aurais tu pourrais avoir
les meilleures formations s'étaient
postés en ville au
delà mépris ou honteux toujours physique
des indiens ces salles des sauvages des
profiteurs
je dirais
ça va rester et c'est au tour de mélanie
d'apprendre à vivre avec les préjugés
joliette est prêt et c'est stigmatiser
lancement a fait qu'on a peur en ce
qu'ils mangent et notre travail à
joliette et est revenu dans le coup ce
que nous ont été pendant des lunes et
des lunes qui ont les encartés j'ai
beaucoup de compassion envers les
infirmières qui travaillent à l'hôpital
parce qu'effectivement sont stigmatisés
dans le reste du québec puis ils le sont
à travers le canada puis pour avant
travers le monde ils savent que yaya
existe un hôpital à geôliers notre
acteur qui décide et là dans des
quantités trop vite et on a mis en
images sur cette réalité là qui nous
étaient apportées l'onl avec des images
tacleur le ministre croit que la mort de
jesse et chaque one a eu l'effet d'un
électrochoc pour les québécois mais il
est toujours pas question d'en parler
comme une victime de racisme systémique
de charlesbourg est systémique le les
gens ce qu'ils ont dans leur position
complètement je suis à passer mon
message quand je vois que les gens
veulent je veux garder le momentum le
plus longtemps possible et pour
conserver la mémoire de joyce à la
demande de sa famille le gouvernement
lui dédiera un endroit près de manouane
me réserve de biodiversité
après le nom de joyce et chaque round
mais notre intention de le faire avec la
famille au moment qui est important
mais l'année jolie ian craig malgré tout
que le drame de joyce et chaque one
tombe dans l'oubli qu'il faut juste
espérer c'est que ce soit pas juste de
la poudre aux yeux pas juste montrer aux
gens qu'on on ne comprit puis quand vous
servez mois
pour qu'elle soit décédée pour juste
faire une
contraction pas besoin de m'en parle
plus des gens pour vous vraiment qu'il y
ait quelque chose qui se fasse plus que
ça perdure dans le temps ici valérie
gamache radio canada manoian